hey guys welcome back to bone shaker
today I work on the right side of the
Main Street which is going to be pretty
similar to the left side the general
idea is that it's kind of this
symmetrical ish Street so as you
approach from the entrance being the big
iron gates you kind of just have this
Street on with buildings in both sides
and right in the middle of that have the
station in the distance as I sort of a
disney castle would be in the Main
Street in Disneyland that kind of idea
so I wanted to make sure that both sides
are more or less just about the same in
measurements and have the same style to
make the area just feel a bit more
coherent and actually make it this nice
transition into the area but I did want
to have some you know unique qualities
to all of these buildings so they're
gonna be pretty different in how the
details are laid out or how they're made
but they're going to share the same
heights and you know the general sort of
characteristics so for this building for
instance I want to go for the similar
thing as the building on the other side
and have the arches on the first floor
and some simple windows in the second
floor have some of these pillars but
then again I'm using different pillars
and I'll be used in different ways to
make the arches it's that kind of thing
and something else which I haven't
really talked about in the last video
but I only got one comment about which I
was kind of surprised by is the fact
that I made these pieces out of one and
a half tile parts and basically copy
those over as separate buildings to be
able to connect them which can be kind
of a hassle sometimes but I wanted to
not make these within separate buildings
just to be able to be a bit more
flexible with that and especially in
this case I needed to get different
rotations of the same piece within the
same building so while in the end it's
going to look like one building it isn't
really going to be one particular
building since the different parts of
the building are made up of different
buildings technically and one of the
reasons why I also wanted to do that is
that I could make these pieces of the
building one and a half tiles wide
because I feel that's a little bit of a
bit a better measurement in this case
since the in-game grid seems to act
well almost precisely as the grid in
Veliko second three apart from the fact
that I can be moved in that it's a four
by four meter wide grid and the standard
walls are also four meters high and are
sort of the very standard measurement
that only windows conform to if you can
form them to the walls and the sort of
standard measurement that you have to
get between windows and it's something
that I didn't really want to go for like
I generally try to avoid it a little bit
and especially in this case I felt it
would be better to use two windows on
one and a half tile square buildings
because the thing is if you have like a
four meter wide wall and you just place
one window per each four meters that's
just a little bit too sparse I feel like
there's a lot of room left between the
different windows but on the other hand
if you place two windows within one four
meter wide wall section then it's kind
of really crammed and you don't really
have any space left in it anymore
so I just figured it would be best to
divide this into two windows per one and
a half title square parts and just to
make things but easier divide all those
one and a half tile parts into separate
buildings which also allowed me to
really go into details with these parts
and just be able to copy that over later
to prevent having to spend many
different hours on just trying to get
all these details over the entire
buildings alright though I do have to
say a pretty major section of this
time-lapse which consisted of well over
an hour of gameplay turned out to be
just me working on the dome which is
kind of stupid in hindsight and I kind
of regret that'sthat's one hour closer
to death just for building a stupid dome
in this game which I am just about to
get to actually but it's kind of alright
I've got plenty of things that I also
want to talk about after I just kind of
finished that discussion about the
one-and-a-half tile part because one of
the issues that I had with that that I
completely forgot in the last video is
that I still had that door on the bottom
floor and wow it works alright to divide
the building into different sections
when it comes to the windows because
they're all pretty much repetitions of
the same theme throughout the entire
building I ended up having five
different doors
on the last building which is not so
great so I'll avoid that for this
building and in future purposes as well
and I kind of want to get back to that
building and get rid of the ridiculous
amount of doors but that's village is
one of the rare it downsides now when it
comes to this dome I also have to
quickly say I wanted to copy this over
like I usually do it like the best
approach to doing this is to just make
one section of the dome have it be on
grid so you can actually copy it just
make like one quarter of the dome and
then select that either by dragging with
the left mouse button or clicking the
left mouse button on the pieces while
holding ctrl that should answer quite a
couple questions that I got and yeah
that's just a really efficient way to do
it
but in this case this dome is just
completely off grid you can actually see
me trying to copy one thing over at some
point in this time-lapse which just
already happened but it didn't really
work since it's so ridiculously off-grid
so I had to make the entire dome myself
which turned out to be more time
consuming then I figured beforehand and
also more time consuming than I had
hoped
but this is probably a good opportunity
to talk about the video for e3 of planet
coaster even though this is a very
topical at the moment but it's probably
not gonna be relevant anymore
if you watch this video back in the
future so I'm sorry about that but I
kind of just want to quickly mention it
because I've gotten some amazing
comments after e3 and I haven't been
able to really reply to all of them
personally so I just want to take this
opportunity to thank everybody for all
the comments so yeah there we go thank
you for all the comments but I also want
to talk about something a bit more
serious because there are also many
comments about the fact that it's that
there's like a lot of stuff from me in
the video and not so much from the rest
of the community which and I don't want
to start down talking the video and down
talking my own stuff here but I kinda do
again because it does seem kind of
strange to have a community creations
video which is just so much of my stuff
which I've also worked for of course and
I have to say I nearly shat my pants
when I got the requests to make some
stuff for it
and I'm definitely really happy that
I've been able to get that chance but I
just want to take this bit - I guess
participate a bit in this discussion and
give some suggestions and y'all some
viewer suggestions in the meantime
because there are some really amazing
people out there who don't get as many
views or appreciation just in general
that I can just really recommend
especially if you don't really know
about too many planet coaster stuff and
you're looking into more stuff but you
can't really find it in any case you can
always follow me on Twitter shameless
plug here
I usually retweet a lot of stuff that I
find that people made in the game that's
really awesome but there are also some
really cool creators on YouTube or
elsewhere that are definitely worth
checking out if you're still looking for
some more aesthetics driven things like
the things that I'm doing here big very
big inspiration for me has to be
Cucamonga on his YouTube channel but
he's also on pretty much all other
social media I think his stuff is really
amazing you might know him of the
Colosseum Fame he actually recently
built an airship an airship modeled
after the in-game airship just with all
sorts of like objects and actually put
like an air balloon on top of it to make
it like a blimp kind of steampunk
airship which is really amazing so
definitely go check his stuff out
there's also too many people to really
shout out but like if you're still
looking for suggestions I can definitely
recommend out of the top of my head and
for TV it's really good feel free the
bear is really good as well
pieces of mystique is pretty awesome
there's Rudy Ram Kemal who is also
really cool he's actually built the
stadium of the Europa or the European
soccer thing that's going on at the
moment that I don't follow because I'm
Dutch he's actually rebuilt the stadium
that's been used for that which is
absolutely amazing and there are
probably a couple of people that I
forgot but there are just many different
things many different channels that you
can check out for more planet cursory
stuff beside you know me as in general
being a study
driven there's also a lot of awesome
stuff on reddit or on the planet coaster
forums and definitely amazing stuff at
shyguys world whoo I also kind of want
to shoutouts Jake see for his amazing
roller coasters he's not so much into
scenery but he makes some really cool
realistic rollercoasters has actually
made an RMC lately which is really
something that I didn't believe actually
was possible and it actually is really
convincing as well so yeah that's Jack
that's that for that plug-in in general
I just figured I don't really find any
other opportunity to plug these people
that well and this is probably the best
opportunity that I have to do so because
there's just a huge group of people out
there who do when I do basically but
don't get as much recognition for it and
earn the flabbily keys or conflict nerds
or flux trances or sky storms of this
world see how that it's something that I
kind of wanted to critique a bit and
also something that I do want to talk
about a bit especially because these
buildings really suffer from this one of
the things that I also kind of picked up
from the community creations video and
that it's definitely something that I
have to agree with as well is that as
amazing as this game is at the moment
and like there is no way to describe how
happy I am with this game that wouldn't
be well an understatement really because
it's pretty much a game that I've been
waiting for for ten years if not twelve
years
damn Azkaban but um actually it's been
nearly 12 years roller coaster contree
came out in 2004 but yeah yeah one of
the things that is still something that
I kind of can critique about this is
that even though the game looks really
amazing and you can build just about
anything already with very limited
pieces something to keep in mind is that
you're not so much building buildings as
you're just putting different objects
together to make something that looks
like a building just to paraphrase and
seven from shyguys world a bit because
the problem with this is that you're
just using many different objects to
make something that for instance looks
like it's a dome but in reality it's
just a bunch of wooden odds and ends
that are all just
randomly put together to make this
awesome shape but in the end you're left
with just so many surfaces and parts of
details that you don't actually see but
it's still there which is most visible
at the back of these buildings which you
might see flashing by in this time-lapse
now and then and it's one of the issues
that make this game not just less
friendly to users because you do you
have to go like great miles if you
actually want to do something outside of
the given themes even though it's
possible it takes a lot of effort to put
all the pieces together in certain ways
to make it look convincing it's also
just well completely terrible for any
computer that you're playing on because
the game is actually really well
optimized already for especially the
early alpha that it's in and I'm really
surprised with how well it runs but it
just eventually dies because you're
using all of these different objects and
you've got all these surfaces and
polygons that you don't actually see
because they're in the middle of
buildings but are actually being
rendered by a computer which is one of
the reasons why this park itself already
has less than half the framerate that I
started it on and why grizzly Valley
like so much despite not being that big
it's not so much a fault of the game
itself it definitely runs really well
already but it's kind of a limitation of
the current building system like there
are more or less ways to overcome these
scenery limitations that we have in the
moment because of the amazing building
system but I don't think it should be us
it should be a substitute for more
contents because at the moment it's more
or less just a cheat
but it kind of comes at a price as well
it doesn't make things much easier nor
for you or your PC so that's something
that I think is worth thinking about as
well and some people have claimed it's
kind of like you know looking at the
trailer it's kind of like you're like a
deception like people see things that
aren't actually in the game they're just
kind of made through playing with what
the game gives you really in a really
smart way I guess but then again I don't
think that's quite a problem because in
the end it is just a sandbox game and
it's more or less with sandbox games
have always been about it's just that
there is still a lot to do especially in
the content section and even though it's
really amazing what we can do with the
building tools at the moment that
shouldn't be a reason to be completely
content with them and truth be told if
it's if there's anything the game
developers can use better than praise
it's just constructive criticism so I
figured I would just throw that out
there and maybe have some good
discussions about it anyway coming back
to the Main Street itself I I have a bit
of catching up to do
I wanted to get some chimneys in there
somebody actually posted a comment about
that and that was surprising because it
was just one person but it's something
that I really needed to get in there
since it's a very English thing
especially the English chimneys are
pretty recognizable and since the
buildings aren't so industrial I wanted
to get some chimneys and some good old
smoke vsv effects in there just to make
it a little bit more industrial than it
was looking and on the other hand I
wanted to have some of those planters
and happy little trees just to make
everything look a bit more inviting and
alive since you know the buildings in
general to you is very pretty dark
industrial colors and this is a theme
park after all like this might be a
steampunk theme but it's also a
steampunk theme within a theme park and
that's something I want to consider as
well so I do want to keep it quite
lively on the foliage and no other
decorative elements and I just wanted to
have a bit of foliage around this path
this path doesn't really lead anywhere
it's just to make this part of the park
because supposedly it's one part of a
larger park to make it look as if it
could realistically be connected to
another Park anyway that is just about
it for the time-lapse section but I do
still have a real-time section so I'm
gonna give it over to my realtime
partner here there are a couple things I
want to go over because even though I
will make like a final video to this
series I hope that answers a couple of
questions that I've been getting by the
way I don't really talk in the plane on
video so it's not really a good spot to
actually talk about some of the choices
that I made and what works better than
just doing it in real time actually be
able to show off this sort of main
angles that I wanted to get
done the first and most important one
for the main street which only kind of
works now that it's finished is like the
way that you arrive this is almost sort
of symmetrical kind of feeling to it
it's almost like Disney Main Street
except it's really small this time but I
didn't want to get some symmetrical ish
sort of element to this that obviously
the station itself is not symmetrical
now there are the buildings on the sides
but they do have a sort of symmetrical
quality to them with similar Heights and
similar designs and both were like a
tower on the corner and the station in
the back though I have to say this path
is not entirely straight to the station
which you can tell right here and it
only kind of looks symmetrical as you
approach it but it actually isn't really
straight or anything what works really
well as well by the way is to thank that
if you just kind of walk into this area
you automatically see the coasters so
it's really quite like we nee that draws
you towards seeing the coaster itself
and the way that it sort of wraps itself
around this here with all the scenery
and stuff like that and you might have
noticed I added another path over here
which doesn't really serve any type of
function but the idea behind this area
in general is that it could be like a
part of a park so I won't finish this as
in a real park it's just like one themed
area so say for instance like the
Arabian point of Disneyland or something
like that and so I wanted to make sure I
had like two entrances to be able to
connect it to be hypothetical park which
it is supposedly part of and I figured
this would be a really good main
entrance as you really see the station
from that direction and this could be
like a little side path from which you
can enter the area as well which
actually works quite well because it's
on the same side line of the of the main
two towers of the coaster as well as the
station so you do kind of have a really
interesting view over here and the same
goes for this area unlike the path over
here it also lines up with the bridge
and the towers in the background and I
don't really think I'll be doing much
else because it's probably quite
important to talk about what I want to
do in the future because there's only
one episode left more
and it can be a quite messy episode it's
not really dedicated to anything in
particular just in general finishing up
the things that I still needed to be
finished and touching up a few things
that are not entirely good at the moment
but I don't think I'll really work with
this much anymore maybe a few details if
I really feel like it but I actually
want to keep this empty I've gotten some
good suggestions actually one pretty
recurring one was to try to get like a
mineshaft in here maybe even do
something with the conveyor belts in
this area and while I feel it would be
really interesting and definitely more
cool to kind of fly over from the
coasters perspective I don't think it
would work that well if you look at like
the ride in general because at the
moment I'm pretty happy with how this is
sort of like one ring that's not so
scenery heavy so you kind of still know
what you need to look at like if you
were to look at the coaster at the
moment you still have the the main hero
as a sort of mains rolling point and
there's nothing over here to really
distract you from it I do probably want
to get some more heavy foliage or rock
work or small scenery and details over
there but there's nothing to really like
make this one big just field of scenery
everywhere and having too much detail to
really notice anything and it's just
something that I don't really want to
have so just to keep everything a bit
more clear
a bit more coherent I think I'll just
leave scenery out over here to keep the
focus on what's the most important and
highest point of the ride itself and
over here I figured it would be cool to
have a little Queen and kind of
nineteenth-century mentioned ish
restaurants it's not going to be too big
but just a nice restaurant so I can
continue the sort of urban line that you
have on this side with the coaster and I
still wanna do something with the break
run though I'm not entirely sure what I
can really do with it
summing Machinery ish with gears and
metal and all sorts of machinery stuff
is basically what I'm looking into even
though I'm not entirely sure how I'm
gonna tackle that and then obviously
there is the building's the Baxter
buildings for the main street that need
to be done and there's a little bit of
foliage but not that much actually and I
kind of want to keep the foliage a
little bit distance and not have too
much foliage in the ride itself so this
should be more or less how it's going to
work
oh it's in the end and yeah just one
more episode with a bit of touching
stuff up and it's probably time for
groups a new thing so thank you guys for
watching this episode or parts I should
say I hope to see you guys in the next
one